hey guys it's just eight and today we're
unboxing something really interesting
this is called circle now what circle
does is it basically allows families to
be able to manage internet consumption
you're able to track and limit and
censor different types of content that
is being distributed on your network and
what's great about this is you can allow
different types of access for different
age levels it is one easy to manage
solution I'm sure most of you guys
watching this may be younger and you're
like no I want to be able to visit any
website that I want to but obviously I
think in most households there is some
sort of limitations placed on the
internet so I'm sure if you guys aren't
getting good grades or something like
that you may be grounded from the
computer or maybe that was just me but
there was no easy way to do that back
then like my mom would just take the
keyboard so with this what I love about
it is it is opening a communication in
the dialogue between families it limits
time spent it censors websites that you
shouldn't be on but it also has a really
cool reward system so say maybe you got
an a on a test or in the case of this
video my sister is going to be
restricting my internet access maybe I
did something nice for Jetta so she
rewards me an extra hour so lets unbox
and get ready for jenna to restrict my
internet access for a day
thanks to circle for sponsoring this
video it's going to be so fun
meet your circle here it is
oh it's not very big at all another
thing is my first thought was okay well
what if I decide to unplug a circle it
has a battery backup built in so nice
try boom start here so I'm also gonna
have to set this up on Jenna's phone
because she's gonna be acting as my
parent this is a nice little box so Rina
set up my profile on Jenna's phone now
what this means is she is acting as my
parent so she's gonna be setting up the
child profile and then she'll be able to
link my child profile to my mobile
device with the same app so let's type
in my name let's spell it properly let's
choose an existing photo let's see
there's a nice healthy let's filter
Justine as a kid these are all the
things that I would be allowed to have
access to Amazon Cartoon Network Club
Penguin Island so I'm gonna say I'm not
allowed to have abscess de Amazon
because I shop too much save let's see
my time limits I think that I should be
allowed to have
two hours of Internet a day could I do
it can I even do this okay but it's done
Oh a bedtime okay I want to go to bed at
7:00 p.m. okay I'm right I wake up at
like 5:00 a.m. so this is not gonna work
out
I'd like my bed time to be 7 p.m. and I
wake up at 5 a.m.
okay that's great done add a mobile
device now I need to download the circle
app on my phone set up as a kid device
I'm going to add a mobile device here by
scanning the QR code done we've helped
my phone's called Pig phone so add a
device esteem has been added to the
circle success I really do like having
this location feature because that's one
of the things that actually my entire
family uses we all use find friends on
each other because it really is
something that is comforting to know
where people are at all times
some of you may not like that but I am a
huge fan of it this is so exciting okay
this is me I'm I'm a kid I'm normal look
at my time loads F two hours left this
is my countdown between two bedtime
wait I only have three hours more to be
awake I'm gonna give myself a reward I'm
gonna I'm gonna give myself a light
bedtime tonight okay
I said 8 p.m. oh my gosh my reward is
here
I've just got a reward from my bad time
at 8 p.m. tonight holy crap I'm so
excited
wow I'm really I'm surprisingly enjoying
this I'm enjoying this a lot now let me
set up my circle so this is connected to
my router so we can get this whole
process started and ready for Jenna but
look at that guess who got an extra hour
before bedtime
yeah me I got a reward so the setup is
pretty easy I've got it plugged in
there's a power button in the back but
I've already pressed and when you plug
this into our router there's a little
setup here that says set up circle home
plus and click room at your house
connect your Wi-Fi router at centers 4
column next to it done it's looking for
it
updating my circle home plus ok this is
cool everything's happening everything's
happening oh man my sister is gonna love
being able to control my internet access
what's crazy about this is it will show
everything that is connected and I have
a lot of connected devices in my house
this is saying it's gonna take several
minutes but it's probably gonna take 3
years here things are happening the
imacros don't mean oh my gosh it's
connected pull the label we look at all
these things that are just popping up
we've got all of my lights that are
connected these are my home pods ok so
I'm gonna hit done this is great
ok well let's go so Justine has already
used 3 hours of her time and that was
all she was supposed to have for the
entire day and the day just started
she's in trouble
no I don't even do it ok I know I know I
know I know what's the problem is I
didn't realize that the music that I was
listening to this morning was on the
internet I was on Spotify and I used
three hours while I was cleaning I was
cleaning up to prepare for the shoot
today where did you think the music was
coming from is the question I'm sorry
ok I made a mistake I learned my lesson
so now going forward
can you please grant me some more time
just I mean I know that you have a lot
of work to do so I feel like I can let
this one slide ok think of one one
mistake making my mom was saying one
that's it mama save you three more hours
oh my gosh so we could ask for like one
I was
b13 you said it you said it you said we
have it on film three hours okay
come on all right I sent you a reward of
three hours oh my gosh you did because
it just showed up in my phone hold on a
second look look look this is so
exciting okay I just got a reward my
total time limit has been extended by
three hours today well I hope you're
enjoying that time because that probably
just took up a minute oh my gosh you're
right you're right you're right okay
okay okay I'm done I'm done I'm done I'm
done I'm gonna go do my work okay um I'm
watching you while you are this is fun
oh I forgot Mario maker is out oh you
said you were working on the video that
you own we're playing it up oh my gosh
okay so okay no no no no I know this
vlog on Ian
no this isn't even oh come on it's like
you just have one job if you do your job
then you can use the rest of your hours
I feel like I'm taking away an hour
No
okay well this is pause so I can't do
anything so I guess I'm taking my laptop
and I'm going to go edit don't make me
be helicopter mom okay fine I'll be over
here
alright just remember I can see you but
no I mean Jenna's right this video is
due today and I'm already wasting my
hours away but I just sit down get this
done then maybe she'll reward me with a
later bedtime maybe what are you doing
you're watching a show well I hope that
you're almost done with your show
because I have limited you to 15 more
minutes of watching it so have fun well
I'm gonna take those 15 minutes
[Music]
so at this point I have no choice but to
get this video done because I've already
expired my time limits and what's cool
is I can see my time limits I can see
what's expired Spotify and Netflix both
are expired and right now I have 2 hours
and 40 minutes left of my total time
allotment and I have a video to shoot
later so hopefully I won't go over my
time limit because I do have to post
some social media stuff about it I've
done 55 minutes of email today I think
I've been super productive okay
she finally sent me the video I'm so
proud of her maybe I'll reward her with
a later bedtime in some Instagram access
I know she really likes Instagram where
she falls asleep the only problem is
she's supposed to be filming right now
we're setting up to film so weird I
checked your location and it says she's
here but I can't find her
this happens when I lose the dog and the
dog is usually outside are you outside
what are you doing she's not working I
have a vitamin D deficiency yeah but you
have a shoot 10 minutes ago
how'd you find me I think your location
one sorrow for my slump they cook inside
do you garage but I have a vitamin D
deficiency I needed the Sun that's fine
but get your work done okay oh my gosh
the sun's not going
yelling at me
TV time TV time TV time TV time Jenna
get over here it is TV time I've done
all of my chores okay you did and you
should watch your video you got that
done yep
all right fine I've been watching I was
a good girl and did all my tasks and
this is what I get what else do you want
me to do me to make you some rice
krispie treats Oh what do I get if I
make them for you what do I get up for
negotiation
I would like 20 minutes of Instagram
time please my lady
only if you tag me okay deal all right
30 minutes 30 minutes protag 30 minutes
are two tags two tags two stories okay
I'm on it done yeah yeah Wow social
currency is real this was such a fun
experiment but it was really crazy
because you don't really realize how
much time you spend doing things like
three hours on Spotify this morning I
had no idea I look to my phone I was
like oh I'm in trouble it's true I mean
sometimes I'll just like catch myself on
their Instagram and I'm like how did I
just waste an hour of my life you never
know what's going on you can waste so
much time you should go outside and play
you should go outside and play one thing
that I feel like I need to restrict
myself from is using my phone before bed
I feel like that interferes with my
sleeping you don't really sleep very
well no I and like even when I just wake
up like the middle of the night I just
gonna reach over and I grab my phone
that's the worst thing to do because
then you're just all amped up on
Instagram and Twitter
sure I'm guilty left mm-hmm how was your
experience it was definitely interesting
and it really did make me more aware of
how much time I was spending doing
things like honestly what I loathe that
phone was like
five three hours I think that it also
keeps you on track because you actually
can't go on Instagram
you can't watch your show so I think I
need that for myself because I'm easily
distracted I also think it's kind of
interesting so if you guys have this in
your house and your parental unit is
controlling it you can negotiate I'll
take out the trash for an extra thirty
minutes I will sweep the floor for an
extra maybe 15 minutes of Instagram time
or you don't have to negotiate you can
just do it and maybe be rewarded I chose
usually right I'm usually wrong this is
what we like to hear people anyway this
was a really fun experiment so circle
thank you guys so much for partnering
with me in this video this was really
fun and Jenna thank you for restricting
Maxo oh of course any time guess what
honestly it's the only way I can get you
to do anything good sir I know it is
very true well I still have about 20
minutes of internet access so I'm gonna
go finish my Netflix your way dad can't
watch today I mean there's a Netflix big
fish machine this is way you talk about
it but we can you look pretty - no come
on
[Music]
did you go to Spain or something yeah I
did look at my tongue you can have your
20 minutes yes I'm easily bought